das bedeutet dass dann aber für den
heute show zuschauer zum beispiel
transparent heute zuschauer bedeutet das
dass wir eventuell mit diesem
transparent begriff die möglichkeit
haben die den berliner sumpf und das ist
natürlich eine frage war nicht unser tag
[Musik]
yao lifa die etablierten haben
abgewirtschaftet hier in berlin feiern
die piraten immer noch und sie
übernehmen jetzt politische
verantwortung und zwar mit ganz klaren
themen und vor allem mit sehr präzisen
aus sagt das wichtigste weshalb wir
eigentlich hier gewählt worden sind ist
die ist wirklich wie der begriff der
transparenz so werden die akzente
gesetzt
sicherlich beim thema transparenz also
sie sind gerade auf der tour mehr
transparenz transparenz transparenz
transparenz die stoßrichtung mehr
transparenz in das sagen transparenz an
sich ist ja nun auch es ist ein stück
breitmacht entzug transparenz ist das
nicht auch gefährlich warum ansteckend
oder anstellung
das macht spaß transparenz macht spaß
bedeutet das dann aber für den heute
show zuschauer zum beispiel transfer ihn
heute zuschauer bedeutet das dass wir
eventuell mit diesen transparenz begriff
die möglichkeit haben diesen berliner so
und das ist natürlich eine frage gesehen
da hat in berlin ist eine kreative stadt
passieren wollte ich nicht verstanden
tainment also wie gesagt jugendliche
trinken gehen musik und dem drogen wir
haben zb berliner landesverband liquid
feedback das ist ein gerade auch mehr
privat privacy weil gerade in dem alter
sieht das ist zum beispiel ist ausdruck
der gemeinde zdf-zuschauer privat das
heißt privat deutsch privat heute das
kann man im boden noch schauen wir sind
die
wir sind die die die was jetzt die
fragen stellen die möglicherweise hier
tun weh tun genau richtig
was bedeutet der begriff
der transparenz für die euro bonds also
da haben sie mich insofern auf dem
falschen fuß erwischt
ja natürlich banken führen wir das auf
zweiter
[Musik]
und damit zurück zur oliver reck ins
trudeln was soll mir was wäre mit ja
[Applaus]